hey
get it open on it hey you think he's
gonna show bring the whole goddamn place
tight focus will be out of here before
anyone can stop us Christ move in
Gordon through all the 52nd floor I'm
going in hey wait wait for backup don't
need it take the stairs I heard stories
you know say three home in an ambulance
the rest in body bags one of the cops
want him dead hey you ever seen him yeah
Gotham Zoo on the other flight handle
you
Bruce you can't keep doing this I have
to no one else will every drop of blood
everything you've sacrificed the city is
safe for now it has made you a target
and people will keep you in the
crosshairs until you shut out of the sky
I can handle it [ __ ]
he'll deke all whatever got in don't let
it get out
what's that
back-to-back Circle up
oh hell is this
I know you're trying to create a myth
but be careful you don't turn into a
monster sometimes you need a monster
come back come on
didn't your mother teach you to knock
behind you big boy
stay where you want you're under arrest
you want to be intimidating you're
succeeding criminals are becoming afraid
of you so are the police it's a scare
tighter gal just a performance
without a scratch so far
that doesn't belong to you I was
wondering if we'd cross paths you broke
the law Here I am cut the [ __ ] the law
don't tell me that's why you do all this
squeeze into a suit tie on a cape most
people dressed up like that end up in
Arkham no one else will are the only one
who gets the job done sounds lonely
gotta admit it though you give a good
chase one day you might actually catch
me tonight don't you know not to corner
a wild animal it's dangerous and let's
put you in a cage bring it bat
closer
it's over I wouldn't be so sure
well now he's gonna wait wait wait do
not shoot
why go to all that trouble for this [ __ ]
a myth can't be killed you however are
flesh and blood dad damaged protect on
shooters no wait
oh yes I was wrong about you catching me
not sure if it was for my sake o yours
give up there's no way out give me some
credit
by bad
step out of the shadows and be Bruce
Wayne tonight that's a much harder fine
don't let tombstones be your family
legacy mother
time to save the city
you